i wanted to start with bad boys for life
because it ended up being a huge hit
and i'm curious uh what what were you
hoping for in terms of like worldwide
box office because it did a lot better
than people anticipate
well we're sad it hasn't been exposed to
china yet but hopefully we'll get there
uh but it was a phenomenal success we're
so excited by it the guys made a
terrific movie
uh will and martin are just wonderful
together they
really worked hard on the script and
during the shooting and it certainly
shows on the screen
so it's the number one picture of the
year uh so far
exactly um how much i heard after with
all the success that you guys might be
developing another one
house how much does the studio want to
do a fourth and
and you guys well we had a great
experience on the first one
uh both through the development process
with tom rothman and his team and then
uh through the editing process and the
filming process and then
uh during the the fact that we
preview process went terrific and we put
together along with their help
a movie that's very satisfying for the
audience and we'd like to do it again
and i think they would like us to do it
again we're
currently working on a draft for the
fourth one